narcissism the excessive interest or
admiration for oneself and ones physical
appearance there's nothing wrong with
looking in the mirror and being happy or
proud with what you see but I think we
can all agree that being a narcissist
isn't great if you've ever wondered
where the term came from or in this case
who the term came from the answer is
narcissus a relatively minor figure in
Greek mythology it's also the name of a
specific type of daffodil we don't
really know if the flower was named
after the myth or the myth after the
flower but his mother also shares her
name with a flower so there is a
connection there narcissus himself was a
young hunter from the town of thespia in
the region of Beau Asia which pretty
much just means central Greece the son
of a river god and a nymph he was widely
celebrated across Greece for his beauty
in the works of hygiene as he's
described as one of the most beautiful
young men along with the likes of Adonis
Ganymede and hermaphrodite asst so
naturally he had many suitors both male
and female
however narcissus as I'm sure you've
gathered was a bit of a narcissist he
was incapable of feeling love for anyone
except himself in his eyes no one could
match his beauty so how could he
possibly fall in love the problem of
this approach is you're going to reject
a lot of people and those people are
gonna be upset so when they start
praying to the gods to spite you that's
when you run into trouble and that is
what happened to narcissus there are two
main stories that involve a spurned
lover the most recognizable is the story
of echo and narcissus which is detailed
in book three of Ovid's metamorphoses
this story involves a mountain nymph
named echo who as her name would suggest
could only echo back the last thing that
was said to her however she wasn't born
this way Zeus ordered echo to help him
hide one of his affairs from his wife
Hera but when she eventually found out
as she always does echo
punished for the role she played because
she lied Hera took away her ability to
speak she could only repeat back the
last thing that was said to her just
like an echo
one day when wandering through the
forest she came across narcissus and
fell instantly in love to not make her
presence known she followed him from a
distance but when he heard the snapping
of branches he turned and called out
who's there she could only repeat back
what he said and narcissus took this as
his voice echoing through the forest and
continued on his way
the longer echo followed the more her
heart swelled until she could hide no
longer she revealed herself and placed
her arms around narcissus and this is
where in most love stories they kiss and
embrace and blah blah blah not in this
story he removed her arm and told her to
get out of his sight he could never love
anyone like her or more accurately he
could never love anyone who wasn't
himself she would then spend the rest of
her life in those woods alone and
heartbroken until she just faded away
and the only thing that was left was the
sound of an echo the goddess nemesis had
been observing narcissus and found his
behavior to be questionable once she had
heard of what happened to echo she
decided it was time that this behavior
was finally punished one morning when
narcissus was out hunting he saw
something in the distance that caught
his eye this was nemesis luring him to a
pool of water thirsty from the hunt he
knelt down to take a drink in that pool
of water he saw the most beautiful thing
he'd ever seen and this time it was
narcissus who fell in love instantly
what he was looking at of course was his
own reflection but to him it was an
entirely different person he was so
taken aback that he couldn't bring
himself to leave he gazed endlessly at
his own reflection until he realized
this love could never be reciprocated
it's at this point some say he finally
understood what it felt like to love
someone who could never love you back in
his shame and despair he killed himself
his blood pooling and forming a white
and gold flower
now there are numerous endings to this
story in Ovid version he finally feels
the burning passion that comes of love
and he just melts away leaving only a
flower in his place in one version he
simply dies of thirst
despite that can straight into a pool of
water fearing that if he moved the image
in front of him would disappear forever
he just remains still until he dies of
thirst and again he turns into a flower
there's also another version where his
punishment is to stare eternally into
that pool of water the nymph seeing him
as they strode past everyday eventually
took pity and transformed him into the
narcissus flower the second story comes
from a method Rafa called Conan his
story instead involves a young man named
ananias who just like many before him
made the same mistake of falling in love
of narcissus in this case narcissus was
harsher than usual he gave the young boy
a sword and told him to remove himself
from his sight the young boy upset and
heartbroken took things a step further
using the sword to kill himself in front
of narcissus this didn't really have the
design defect as narcissus didn't seem
to care and just went back to hunting
this however would not be the end of
ominous his role in this story in his
dying breath he called out to nemesis to
give narcissus a taste of his own
medicine
to feel the same pain that he caused the
others the next part of this story is
essentially the same nemesis lures him
to a pool of water where he gazes
endlessly at his own reflection he then
takes his own life as the object of his
obsession is unattainable this variation
of the ending makes more sense in this
story than in the previous because
ammonius died in the exact same way his
dying wish was for narcissus to feel the
same pain and he does so there is
something poetic about the two dying in
the same fashion
there is another variation to this story
that came a few hundred years later
where narcissus falls in love with his
twin sister at the time he didn't know
who she was but after she learns of
their relation she doesn't feel the same
not being able to deal with this
unrequited love he disappears and the
only thing they can find is a flower
the reason the roman version is the most
popular version of this story is because
the ancient Greeks were very
superstitious especially when it came to
looking at their own reflections for
long periods of time believing it was
bad luck and could even lead to death
so when you take that into account this
story does make a bit more sense and you
can understand why it may not have been
their favorite the Romans on the flip
side rather enjoyed this story and many
Renaissance artists took to create him
portraits and sculptures of narcissus
the most famous being narcissus painted
by Caravaggio in the 16th century which
depicts a young man staring at his
reflection by the river we don't really
know for sure why the Romans enjoyed
this story as much as they did but it
may be because this story serves as a
warning to those who valued vanity
possessions and self-preservation over
the needs of the many
before we finish with the morals and
themes of this story it's important to
note that the Greek and Roman versions
do have similarities but they also do
have some differences that may or may
not show a difference in culture I've
not really seen too much discussion
comparing these two stories so I can
only offer you my own thoughts and
observation now obviously one of these
stories is about a man being rejected
and the other a woman but the real
difference is in how they react to the
rejection when Ecco made her feelings
known she just accepted it and went on
to live a sad and lonely existence
she didn't harbor any ill feelings
towards narcissus and nemesis acted of
her own accord when it came to his
punishment in the Greek version M Aeneas
does the exact opposite when his
approaches are rejected he doesn't walk
away if Ecco chose a slow and quiet
death
than ammonius chose to go out in a blaze
of salty glory killing himself and
praying to the gods for vengeance the
Roman approach is tame and pragmatic if
you're wrong by someone then there will
eventually be justice from those in
power the other approach is emotional
and driven by revenge which isn't a huge
surprise when it comes to Greek
mythology many of its stories feature
individuals seeking revenge and taking
situations into their own hands in this
case that was persuading nemesis to
intervene where normally she may not
have the morals and themes remain the
same regardless of the many different
versions on a base level it's a clear
warning to those obsessed of vanity
there's more to the world than what you
see in the mirror you may lose sight of
the bigger picture if you allow your
vanity to consume you it's also a
reminder to be weary of the effects your
actions may have on others narcissus
shows his suitors no respect with not
much thought to how they may feel after
being rejected he only comes to this
realization when he's put in the same
position the most overlooked lesson and
the theme that can be taken away from
this story is the emotional immaturity
of youth it's easy to sit here and say
well he should have known better but
narcissus is always described as a youth
which means he was in his mid-teens an
age where you're likely to do an
incredible amount of stupid things
because you're still maturing being
somewhat selfish and obsessive
appearance at that age is also not
really out of the norm we do see
narcissus begin to mature and understand
that his actions have consequences but
he's then turned into a flower and it's
all pointless to me this ending is
almost saying don't learn from your
mistakes just don't make mistakes in the
first place stupid it's a story with
many different meanings and many
different interpretations some of course
more helpful than others
let me know in the comments section
which version you prefer and what it
means to you as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explain